one million dollars to see where this
[ __ ] hide it
[Music]
I'm comedian Miss Pat and I'm here to
answer the internet
oh [ __ ] they want me to read out loud if
there was only one podcast in the world
who would you want the two podcast hoes
to be me and um Joe Rogan so I can make
the money that he make yes Joe would you
rather only hear one song for the rest
of your life but watch one TV show a
movie one song I would like to hear for
the rest of my life all my life I waited
for someone like you
beautiful that's my song that's my [ __ ]
right there oh my life I'm waiting for
someone like you
what's the worst thing you gotten thrown
out of a bar for
everybody thought I know [ __ ] ball no
never once no that white people [ __ ]
[Laughter]
armed robbery
robbing the damn ball
who the [ __ ] don't black people out the
ball we know how to behave without
scoping out the [ __ ] gonna leave a
pocket but we're not them but me would
you rather never get your nails or hair
done ever again my [ __ ] Nails I need
my hair done I look like a dude I don't
give a [ __ ] was in my nails but hey hey
I got a chance with my hair combed
some people been licking dirty nails
every man don't want you looking like
him
let's take with any two movie characters
who would it be uh
[Applause]
uh tell you [ __ ] phone Pam and a cat
[Laughter]
it'll be my PR person now I can't
[ __ ]
a dog named noodles who the [ __ ] named
they dog noodles white people pick some
real name so you can put the kids on
your food stamps your animals on your
food stamps [ __ ] you name me your dog
noodle for a name him Chantel
that sounds like somebody who can go on
Medicaid
I didn't answer the question if you
could see a sex tape with any two movie
character who would it be Angelina Jolie
and what's the lady name whoever she
took I would like to see Angelina Jolie
and Jennifer Hanson
Hanson you got to know how to speak
patternism to get through that one you
know what only fans is yeah what the
[ __ ] it's a new way to say I'm [ __ ] as
we do I know it only fans yes it took
the prostitution off the corner and put
the [ __ ] in front of a camera
now I'm mad cause they get the same puss
in AC we had to stand on the corner
yeah but we just saying put some water
bottles in our hands
these new holes ain't even got to work
that hard they'd be at the house up
under the AC watching Netflix why they
doing other [ __ ] in front of the camera
I'm jealous
by the time I get off a whole stroll up
and down the street have coins on my
toes my heels I'm busted I'm sweating my
underwear wet these [ __ ] is in the AC
now I hate these hoes
they don't know no struggle selling
[ __ ] they only have to talk it down
back in the day you had to auction to
put hey 20 long [ __ ] I said 25 like 20
I said 25 22 feet
you don't need to do that [ __ ] no more
they hit the amount of money they want
to pay for the [ __ ] and whatever you're
gonna do for that price you pop up there
that's so that's so wrong to the old
hoes like me and quisha
okay what's your number to have an
x-rated only fans account oh what's your
number how much money you want to make
to have an x-ray fan only fans account I
ain't I don't look that good [ __ ] so
I'm gonna need a billion dollars and
have one customer
I don't even want [ __ ] to see me
naked and I can delete that account one
billion dollars to see well this [ __ ]
hide at
because you know I'm over 50 I got that
trick-or-treat [ __ ]
trick or treat [ __ ] you gotta knock on
the door we can't ask for candy oh would
you rather get proposed to at a baseball
game or add a Cracker Barrel there's
some white folk [ __ ] ain't nobody black
ain't no Cracker Barrel
house Waffle House
[Laughter]
if you're watching on YouTube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and John what
should they click if they want
notifications revolver make sure you
click thumbs up for the like hit that
Bell icon
foreign